Let's look at the code again. This is our tile per element kernel. And this syncthreads is the problem.
Remember we have a thread block of K by K threads, and at the moment, K is set to 32.
So, we have a thread block of 1024 threads,
and if you think about it, each thread is doing very little work.
It's reading a single word into shared memory, and then it's waiting around at the barrier
until all the other threads get done with their job, and then it's writing a single word to memory.
So most of the threads in this block are spending most
of their time waiting on the syncthreads call, waiting on this barrier for everybody else to get there.
And the more threads in the block, the more time on average they spend waiting.
So for a simple kernel like this, most threads spend a large chunk of their lifetime
simply waiting at this barrier until the last few threads complete their read operations.
So, what can we do to reduce the average wait time per thread?
Should we eliminate the syncthreads call?
Should we reduce the number of threads per thread block?
Or should we increase the number of threads per thread block,
or perhaps increase the number of thread blocks per SM?